Our Introduction to Optimization tutorial series
is first going to start by having
us take a look at how we think about optimization
throughout the lifetime of our Unreal Engine 5 projects.
We'll then move on to ways we can optimize our projects
right from our project's initial creation.
We'll then take a look at how we can optimize our texture
content, as well as optimize both static and skeletal mesh
content.
We'll then have a look at how we can use Unreal's
materials systems to help optimize our material, as well
as our material workflow.
We'll then take a look at the various optimization view modes
Unreal Engine 5 provides to help us visually debug areas
that could be prone to performance or optimization
issues, and help us provide better ideas on how
to go about solving those performance or optimization
issues.
Finally, we'll take a look at the number of tools
Unreal Engine 5 provides to help us optimize our projects
no matter which platform we happen to be developing for.
We've got a lot to cover, so let's go ahead
and get started with optimization philosophy.